a
y colombianos que viven en australia
salieron a protestar contra el gobierno
de evans duque en las 5 principales
ciudades de este país oceánico las
concentraciones en melbourne sídney
brisbane gold coast y perth estuvieron
cargadas de muestras artísticas y de
mensajes a favor del paro nacional y en
rechazo a la violencia policial contra
los manifestantes el propósito también
era lograr que este lado del mundo sepa
lo que está ocurriendo en colombia y
según ellos estar lejos no es
impedimento para exigir mejores
condiciones de empleo educación salud
seguridad pobreza y lucha anti
corrupción entre otros temas aquí en
australia hay alrededor de 30.000
colombianos y los manifestantes
advirtieron que mientras persista la
crisis en colombia seguirán protestando
al otro lado del planeta
[Música]
la comunidad colombiana en españa lleva
toda la semana movilizándose y a menudo
las protestas tienen lugar como aquí en
barcelona frente al consulado de
colombia los manifestantes obviamente le
piden la desmilitarización del país pero
sobre todo buscan apoyo internacional y
de momento aquí en españa pues la
ministra de asuntos exteriores arantza
gonzález dijo que él llamaba a la calma
y también al diálogo y que seguía con
preocupación lo que ocurría en el país
latino una respuesta que para los
manifestantes es insuficientes estos
manifestantes dejan miles en las calles
de barcelona el pasado miércoles 4000 el
pasado jueves en madrid y este fin de
semana se espera a que haya más gente en
las calles españolas con movilizaciones
más importantes
un manifestante nos comentaba hace pocos
minutos que él iba a acudir cada día a
estas manifestaciones en lo que al menos
aquí puede protestar sin tener miedo a
que le disparan una bala
[Música]
los colombianos en eeuu se ha movilizado
para organizar protestas contra el
gobierno de iván duque miami donde más
del 10% de la población es de colombia
se ha convertido en uno de los puntos
neurálgicos de las protestas y decenas
han participado activamente frente a la
sede consular dicen que se sienten
impotentes y con ganas de ayudar en esta
crisis tras ver las imágenes de los
disturbios que han dado la vuelta al
mundo muchos aún tienen a sus familiares
en el país y temen que aumenten los
casos de violencia por eso los
colombianos han organizado una
concentración para este sábado por la
tarde en el centro de la ciudad de miami
para solidarizarse con sus compatriotas
pero también para rechazar los actos
violentos que se han dado en estos
últimos días la casa blanca ya se ha
pronunciado al respecto a través de la
portavoz adjunta del departamento de
estado de eeuu y al inah a porter la
administración de joe biden ha expresado
su apoyo a iván duque para encontrar una
solución mediante el diálogo desde el
gobierno norteamericano defienden que
todos los ciudadanos del mundo tienen
derecho a protestar de manera pacífica
pero rechazan
[Música]